[Music]
all right let's go out to louville
Kentucky and or as America says
Lewisville and talk to Tera what's up
Tera hey how are you good how are you
I'm okay I'm at work what's that F I
hope that's good sounds fantastic it's
good it's awesome F all right so what's
up um I was calling about our
relationship with our son and his wife
um my question was how can we best
communicate with our son and his wife
that we feel hurt and left out by them
always choosing her side of the family
over us we miss out on seeing our
granddaughter especially during the
holidays because they spend more time
with our daughter-in-law's family and
the multiple branches of her extended
family um I hate that our son feels
pulled both ways and I would never ask
him to choose us over his wife but I
feel that they don't divide the holidays
equally or fairly between our
families how how's that conversation
gone in the past um well it's been only
with our son generally sure because she
doesn't like
confrontation um oh boy this just sounds
gross let me ask you this yeah has your
husband taken your son
out for coffee or a drink or what
however they communicate and they may
not communicate at all but say hey ma'am
I miss you I miss my granddaughter is
there something I've done is there
something that we're doing to make
people feel uncomfortable because I miss
you
guys yeah there's been conversations
both me and him have had conversations
with him okay um we do get to see them
some it just seems like the holidays are
um a little one-sided you know we do we
do they live close so it's not like we
don't see them at all we do
um she has divorced parents and divorced
grandparents as well as a robust step
family through her stepmom and so there
is a lot going on with her you know
especially during the holidays um but
just this past Halloween we got kind of
left out in the cold and it really hurts
and that's not the first holiday it's
happened and I don't look forward to the
rest of the holidays because of it
so have you
guys thrown a holiday party and invited
them and they just have shunned you and
said no they've never completely not
tried to come until Halloween this past
Halloween um usually we get five 10
minutes here there or we maybe get an
hour or we can squeeze you in for 30
minutes you know and they never have
time to do like the full event because
they've got three other things to do
before the day is over
with what do you think it is
I you're smart I think she are y'all let
me are y'all a
lot are we a lot I don't think so I
don't think she agrees with everything
we believe in politically or religiously
okay um but we don't force those things
on her while she's at her house um but
she you know she has opinions and we
respect
them okay we don't try to you know over
you know parent you know try to tell
them how to parent their child or
anything like that um I'm just worried
I'm getting kind of resentful you know
that I have to beg for time with from
for them with them both of them and her
and my granddaughter as well so you've
probably heard me say this on the show
and it's one of the most heartbreaking
things I can
say but behavior is a language so if
behavior is a language what are they
telling
you that don't enjoy being with us
correct yeah and that they'd rather be
with other people no no no no that's you
adding your part to the story
yeah that's you adding that's adding
your little
dig the facts that you
know is that they have repeatedly told
you through their
actions we would rather not be
here and anything else you add to that
is you making up more to the story mhm
and so with what you
have it's not your son's job or your
daughter-in-law's job to fulfill
your invented picture about what
grandparenthood was going to look
like it is I
think especially your son his
responsibility to be an adult and to
have a hard conversation with his mom
and dad dad which he has refused to do
mhm and I think it's fair to say I I I'm
assuming not now you can tell me no
you're wrong
John but I'm assuming the conversation
has not taken place with um your husband
and
him off somewhere just them two over a
Stak or
whatever hey like I just I just need to
know for my own
soul do we do something do we believe in
something do we make you all upset do we
make you mad do we hurt your wife what
happened
and your husband tell your son my
expectation dude is just be honest with
me just tell me the truth
yeah and I know you want to pitch in
there and you never let us do this and I
miss my granddaughter and I want I get
all that but I think that's what's led
to
this
and maybe he has a very very immature
wife
maybe but my wife has 5 Bill 872 million
cousins and all kinds of
family and we
alternate just how we do
it we both love being with both
Crews
do that make
sense yeah I I agree um the husband and
the son have not probably sat down face
to face alone but there has been phone
conversations phone conversations AR
going to cut it not going to cut it and
they all live in the same Community
because here's what usually happens you
get upset and your husband feels like he
needs to take care of you and he calls
and says hey man what's up can't come
for 10 minutes and your son goes all
right Dad we'll be there for 10
minutes oh we'll swing by and they swing
by for 10 minutes and they
leave is that about what happens yeah
probably probably I think your grown-up
husband needs to have a grown-up
conversation with his grown-up
son um I mean I guess if boundaries are
needed I don't I I'm blind to those
issues if that's the case and but I like
to know them probably that may be why
they're creating pretty firm ones
yeah and you may have said something
four years ago that you don't even
remember saying that set off something
in your daughter-in-law's heart and mind
and
body that she experienced and her family
got divorced and she made a commitment
that I'm not going to be a part of the X
Y or Z and you may not even know that's
why I like the invitation I'm going to
be weird and I'm going to go
first and if he says your son looks your
husband in the eye and says dad there's
nothing we got a lot of family to see
and so this is kind of how we do
it then you and your husband have to
grieve the ever loving crap out of this
because that just
stinks and it is and then y'all can
choose um to just extract every second
of those 10 minutes you
get you can choose to send little videos
and write letters and have a on once a
month or once every two weeks we're
going to send a book to the
grandkids we are going to behavior as a
language we're going to act into this
little sliver of space we have to let
you know that we love you we love you we
love you and if your Mom and Dad don't
want us to see you you're never going to
not know that we don't love love you to
the moon and
back see what I'm saying me you can do
what you can with what you
got yeah we've been doing that that's
awesome up until now yes awesome so what
happened to this particular thanksgiv I
mean Halloween that made you
upset um I asked the had of time if they
would just stop by because I knew they
did probably already have PL to go
somewhere and he said yeah we'll stop by
for a few minutes I had a little goodie
bag and a little coloring book I had
bought for her and I wanted to see her
in her costume um you know and the
evening just you know blew by and they
never showed up and you know he texted
to say that she was cold and they went
ahead and went home you know and never
stopped by
so I don't just hurt I don't see a
problem with you taking your son out for
coffee saying hey that that hurt I'm
your mom's at least worth a phone call
to say that you're not coming but I had
stuff he tried to call he tried to call
but I was already crying and upset and
so I wasn't ready to talk about
everything why'd you go
there um because this isn't the first
time and I mean there's always an excuse
you know there's all it's never the
truth I don't guess you know and why is
that a story you've made up potentially
made
up you think your son lies to you every
time no I don't I just don't think he
talks for her you know and I think he
tries to not hurt our
feelings okay does he have does he have
permission to hurt your
feelings for me has he ever had
permission to hurt your feelings as long
as he's been
alive
now guess he needed permission he can do
it if he wants and he
has not really here's what I'm saying um
was it his job to make like like hey
don't do that or your dad's gonna get
mad or hey pick that up your mother's
coming home no I don't think so
okay then it sounds like it sounds like
the adults in his life need to have
adult conversations hey honey i' would
love to take you out for dinner just you
and
me and you can do that his his dad can
do that but I think this dancing around
the topic can you come by for 10 minutes
sure we'll be there you didn't come I'm
weeping hey Mom I'm trying to call I'm
not I can't take your call then
Thanksgiving comes around hey can y'all
swing by for a little bit just to have
some pie sure and then this
whole man just cut all that out just sit
down across the table adult to adult and
say hey I love you and had this picture
in my mind that when you started having
kids we'd have this big time together
and I know your wife has a huge
family what have we
done what have we done what have I done
have I made it hard and I'm a big girl
and you can tell me the like the hard
truth but it's not adding
up or say the say the thing I always say
behavior is a language and it's coming
through loud and clear you you don't
want to be around
us and you're allowed to do that you're
an adult but it breaks my heart and like
what
happened I think you have to be that
clear and that direct and if he looks
you ey and lies to you then that's your
answer and I 100% know that's scarier
than just playing it the 10 minutes by
10 minutes every couple of
months because there's a finality to
that potentially there's a vulnerability
to
it and he might say my wife is simply
uncomfortable with you and your politics
and your religious stuff she's
uncomfortable and then you get to decide
afraid go ahead you're I afraid to
completely lose
them yeah but now you're in resentment
you have lost
him yeah you have lost him cuz you're
not grieving it you're just getting mad
and madder you're just simmering and
simmering and
simmering and your son would say Mom I
tried to call this thing happened my kid
was sick I went to go home and you
wouldn't take my call that would be if
he called my show right now that's what
he would say I tried to call my mom and
let her know she wouldn't even take my
call see how this just goes round and
round and round until somebody saw the
lights on and says I'm I'm done with
this just let's sit down and talk yeah
no I agree we need hard come to Jesus
meeting I guess is what you call it yeah
but it's not a come to Jesus because
when I say when I think of come to Jesus
I think of like hey this is the way it's
going to be and I don't think that needs
to be this meeting this is a
truth-telling meeting this is a
vulnerable you could really hurt me
right now and I'd rather be hurt and
know the truth than just continue to do
this silly little
dance cuz the silly little dance is just
burning us both up he's getting anxious
every holiday season cuz he feels like
he has to display his kid on a trophy
however everybody in the world wants to
see his kid and you have expectations
his wife has expectations his in-laws
have expectations and enough's enough's
enough that's why me and my wife started
sending an email out actually I'm behind
on that I need to get that out we
started sending an email out to all of
our family here's what we're doing this
this holiday season we'd love for you to
be a part of it it might only be 24
hours this year it might be a week next
year whatever that looks like um but
here's what we're doing and then the
adults in our lives get to choose are
they going to be upset they're going to
be happy they're going to be overjoyed
they're going to join us they're going
to not join us that's that's the choices
they're
making or my dad calls and says hey we
would really mean a lot to us if you did
this awesome we're going to try to
figure that
out but it's grownup time talking to
grownup
time no more dancing and by the way I'm
going to strongly suggest you and your
husband don't do this
together cuz it's going to throw your
kid's body back into when he was 9 years
old and he got in trouble for something
and Mom and Dad's sat on either one of
the the chairs in the living room kind
of thing don't do that one of you at a
time probably preferably dad but if Dad
just won't do it then Mom can do it too
and it's not a
tack it is not hey why have you been
that's not what we're doing here it is
man I had a different picture in my head
and I've clearly done something I'm
sorry but I miss you guys what happened
I'm I'm a I'm a grown up I can take it
but please tell me the
truth let all choose reality and start
from there I hate this for you Tera I
hate it hate it hate
it but maybe if you go in with a posture
of humility and vulnerability you might
learn yeah Mom whenever we mention this
you say this and we just not going to be
around that anymore or yeah make it real
uncomfortable with this this and this
maybe you'll hear that and then you'll
have a opportunity to change or an
opportunity to say well that's just the
way I am and um that's my hope for you
guys but let's start with calling it
what it
is let me know how that conversation
goes I'm going to be fascinated to hear
how this one wraps
up